[موسيقى]
قبل نحو 1500 عام في منطقه دورنا ولد
صناجه العرب الاعشى ميمون وقال ابياتا مدح
فيها نخيلها وجمالها درنا منفوحه بجوار
حجر اليمامه شهدت اياما من حياه الشاعر
الذي عرف عنه انه لم ينبح الناس دون ان
يمجدهم ولا يضايقهم دون اذلالهم
كنا في جبل المرقب في منفوحه ونزلنا في
دورنا دورنا التي فيها التاريخ ومع
الدكتور راشد ماذا سترينا في هذا الطريق
الاسفلتي وهذه البنايات المزدحمه هذه
البنايات الان قامت المشاهده الان في
تقريبا اواخر الستينات الميلاديه من القرن
الماضي في عام 1300 تقريبا وخمسه وثمانين
انتقلت الان الارض
الزراعيه وايضا بعض الامور الاثار
المعماريه انتقلت الى بنا حديث بوجود ايضا
توسع الحضاري هنا في هذه المنطقه لكن هذه
المنطقه كانت تسمى قديما وايضا هي سكن
الاعشى وحي الاعشى الشاعر الذي يفتخر بها
والذي يقول وان لنا درنا فكل عشيه يصاق
الينا خمرها وخميرها ولهذا ايضا يقول في
هذا الحي
ويشير في ذلك الى ان هذه المنطقه ايضا
ملاى بالحياه وملء ايضا بالاهالي فيشير
مثلا الى بعض الاوصاف الاجتماعيه فيقول ان
طحن الدرنيه لعيالها تطبطب ثديها فطاره
قطينها هذا الحي المعروف
بقصر الاعشاء او درنا كان الحقيقه هو اثر
ضخم هذا البناء البناء الطيني الذي سكنه
الاعشى وسكنه واله وهو حي درنا الذي سكن
فيه في اسرته وايضا بني سعد بن ضبيعه جزء
منهم هنا هذا المبنى كان تقريبا اكثر
من 15 بئرا ارضيا موجوده في هذا المكان
اضافه الى ان العوامل الاخرى الذين شاهدوا
هذا المكان وجدوا ان هذه الاثار متهدمه
فيما بين البيوت
[موسيقى]